welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss this is phillip molina and this is
more bite sized questions that i'm going
to tackle
fire away phillip our first one for you
is from atkin ray asks
why did red skull call gamora daughter
of
thanos if gamora totally hated him as a
father figure and he definitely wasn't
her biological father so
in what way is he her father you know
that's a good question there's a lot of
mystery around what
red skull called them when he met them
so he called thanos son of a lars
he called gamora daughter of thanos
and then when hawkeye and black widow
showed up
called hawkeye son of edith and natasha
daughter of ivan and that was the whole
thing she didn't know who her father was
and uh people thought it was a freaking
whiplash
yeah i've on vanco and then a son of
edith is interesting because in the
comics
clint barton's mother edith barton uh
was abused by his father
so it's more like oh he's more his
mother's son than his father's son
so getting back to gamora here get back
to work like me even though gamora hates
thanos and even though thanos is not her
biological father he was
he kidnapped her and made her like a
child soldier it shows
i think red skull is able to peer into
your soul and
determine which parent which parental
figure
you have taken the most from in your own
development and you are most similar to
so in that moment it's a it's a sign of
character development for gamora it's
telling us that
even though gamora was taken from her
birth parents
she over the years has become truly a
daughter of thanos
and her behavior and also it's
interesting because
when she was brought back from 2014 and
brought back to the present day
it's interesting in that deleted scene
she doesn't take a knee for tony stark
she walks away because it reminds us
that even though she's a nice
person she's on a she's a good guy she's
one of the guardians of the galaxy
she ultimately is one of thanos minions
and she has that dark side to her
so i think that's what the infinity war
screenwriters are saying by calling her
daughter
especially that's that whole area is
about the soul stun right so it's like
which
figure had the most effect on her soul
right whatever any fool can be a dad
that takes a real
fanny that's right and it sets up the
idea of that emotional
break when thanos does sacrifice right
yeah right okay cool next question
is from joel stauffer he's asking if
disney plus
just loses their minds for some reason
and decides to give you
eric boss an opportunity to produce your
own series around
any star wars character who would it be
um okay my answer a long time ago used
to be boba fett but i feel like we're
kind of checking that block with the
mandalorian now
so thank you there's a character quinlan
voss
that i feel like i kind of have to uh
explore he's gotten a run
on the clone wars he was just one of
these like legends characters
who was in the background of the phantom
menace in subulba's cafe
and then they they gave him this whole
backstory because they did that with
everybody
and then he had a limited run he was
ayla secura's master he's like a jedi's
badass
so if not him um i would love to see a
young lando series like donald glover
lando with l337 because i love phoebe
waller bridge and i think the two of
them are hilarious and i think that
would be a great series with like like a
kind of
sexy like 60 70s vibe sure yeah and
they're kind of like
hooking up in their weird way
it was like the best part of solo and uh
i'd love to see that it'd be a very fun
one especially because it could lean
into the comedy
yeah it would just be kind of a rom-com
ah but before it continued thank you to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
sweet every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and it has zero calories
yet it tastes
real great there's over 20 different
flavors to choose from one of those
great flavors is
bangster berry a berry that i presume
due to mandatory sentencing laws
probably went to jail for a long time
because being a bankster doesn't pay
but it does make a delicious energy
drink check out bang on instagram you
can get
25 off your order at bang energy.com
when you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
they got a sweet tea flavor they got a
keto
coffee flavor you can also get clothing
or fitness supplements all kinds of
stuff to be your best
bang so thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video
get 25 off at bang energy.com using the
code
newrockstars25 austin w
underscore 110 this is the person on
twitter who wants to know
does kylo ren have any naturally as you
would want to know
turn ons or fetishes do i make you horny
well let's think about this
um i know let's sure let's well
the thing that comes to mind for me uh a
lot because how would we know how do we
know better
first of all um he there was that weird
moment in the force awakens when after
chewbacca
shot him with his bowcaster
he smacked his wound he hit it
i think i see where you're going there's
such thing called masochism which means
you get off on feeling and receiving
pain
is that what he was doing does that work
punching your wound no it doesn't pinch
me
really hard hard that's as hard as i
want to pinch anything
okay see and that's why i knew i knew
that was a mistake
wait hold on no yeah oh
yeah that's uh i mean it's certainly a
lot of sensation
i mean when asked about it jj abrams
adam driver i don't think they've given
an answer for it but yeah he's going to
say it's my fetish
some the kind of in-canon answer that
kind of makes sense
is siths get more energy
from embracing their anger their rage
their pain
so he was feeling pain in that moment it
was right after he killed his father
so by hitting himself in that wound it
was kind of like a power up
moment like yes yes make myself more
angry
feel that pain so i'm kind of reading
myself for battle it's almost kind of
like the
henry cavill pump pumping mission
possible yeah you could
i don't know if he got off on it i mean
it's it's a disney movie so we don't
know but i i
i did kind of look up apparently there
is pornography
in the star wars universe oh sweet the
hutts are some real horn dogs
i mean we've seen that yeah he has uh he
has all these sexual pornographic
interests he keeps twilight dancers on
chains
leia and chains and slave clothes
remember when she kills him and she
chokes him and he says you choke me
harder daddy
we might have a bondage kink we don't
know i looked this up all his tongue
does do that yeah
yeah yeah now we know what that means in
hatties
according to the star wars fandom page
belle
dorian had a formidable library of
hattie's pornography and once employed
the hollow faker legious vorn to re-tape
and edit it
re-tape and edit wait which part is
weirder
like like make it again like film it
re-film it
like this where he has to play all the
parts like be kind rewinds yeah
well i hope that's that's the most i
could answer that one i hope it
satisfies you austin
but not in the way no in the way that
you want to be satisfied well that's it
for this week's episode
our black widow super spy assassin's
reel hooters wings
the best wings anna kushienko actually
looks like black widow look at this
picture of her
yes men can be honeypots too and i know
that because we did it to you earlier
wait what no you don't
it's gonna break me forever why does nr
use clickbaity thumbnail the big red
arrows and the thumbnails
the big red circles have you ever
catfished anyone
well i have a reminder to send us your
big questions on twitter using the
hashtag bigquestion or mail us at our po
box address
and subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube and for audio versions of the
show subscribe to the big question
wherever you get your podcast you can
follow us on social media at eavos
and philip molina and subscribe and
follow new rock stars on all social
media as well at the rockstars
see you next week bye you want to do the
like thing again
i've learned my life
[Music]
[Music]
so